In recent times the meetings between the US
President and European leaders have become
quite tense.
The NATO summit, which took place in early
July 2018 has been good proof of that... and
has left some questions on the table:
Is Donald Trump right when criticizing his
European partners?
Are the European NATO countries taking advantage
of the United States Army?
And perhaps most importantly: Should Europe
have an army?
Listen up.
If one thing has become very clear, it’s
that Donald Trump isn’t too fond of these
European leader meetings...
[Simon’s Ironic Mode ON]
How bothersome it is to have to meet with
all these people...
Poor Trump, if they were at least as fun as
Vladimir Putin or Kim Jong Un... it’d be
different.
[Simon’s Ironic Mode OFF]
The fact, dear viewers, is that the clash
between the US Administration and most European
governments extends to virtually all issues:
economy, trade, immigration...
and defense.
See, the US president has been criticizing
NATO for years due to the alleged lack of
involvement of the European partners.
In fact, the US president has been saying
things like that for almost 20 years.
(“America has no vital interest” in Europe.
Their conflicts are not worth American lives.
Pulling back from Europe would save this country
millions of dollars annually”.
Donald Trump, 2000.)
Of course, it isn’t just about the White
House tenant.
The truth is that in recent decades the differences
between Europe and America have expanded.
For example, there’s baseball versus soccer,
an appreciation for cars with gigantic engines
- one can tell where gas is much cheaper - and,
also, the way in which weapons are considered...
in all fields... even in defense.
Yes, the army and the military are very, very
important issues in US politics...
However in Europe... not so much... well,
it’s even worse than not so much.
These aren’t even front page issues and
are certainly not very popular.
Perhaps that’s why, since the cold war ended,
the military spending of European countries
that belong to NATO has collapsed in terms
of GDP; ranging from something a little over
3% to less than 1.5%.
In Europe, military spending doesn’t sell.
And this, dear viewers, has greatly angered
Washington’s politicians in recent years.
And, in this matter, we’re not only talking
about Donald Trump, but also Barack Obama
and George W. Bush.
Here on VISUALPOLITIK, in a previous video,
we told you why it isn’t such a good idea
for European countries to spend more money
on weapons
But... just a moment...
What if Washington was right?
Listen up.
(WHAT IF WASHINGTON WAS RIGHT)
Here’s a question and as always you can’t
Google it: Do you know how many soldiers the
European NATO countries have in total?
Well, approximately 1.8 million soldiers.
However, of this number, only 30% can be deployed
in case of a conflict... and only 50 to 100
thousand can be deployed sustainably and for
greater lengths of time.
And folks, in general, the European armies
have many operational problems.
Yes, it's true, they spend a lot of money...
but their governments, most of them, don’t
really care much about the result.
We can, for example, take a look at Germany’s
case, a country that in 2017 had a military
budget of approximately 45 billion dollars.
That is, it has one of the top 10 largest
military budgets of any country.
Well, despite being one of the countries with
the largest military budget, a couple of years
ago a study by the consultancy McKinsey revealed
that almost 60% of Germany’s Eurofighter
and Tornado fighter aircrafts and 80% of their
most modern helicopters, weren’t ready for
combat, due to a lack of maintenance, updating,
supplies, etc., etc.
At the end of 2017 a parliamentary investigation
showed quite similar results: not one of the
submarines and none of the 14 main transport
planes of the German air force were operational.
Not even one.
You heard that right.
Even a document from the German Ministry of
Defense warned that the soldiers didn’t
have enough protective vests, winter clothes
or tents to participate in any important NATO
mission.
And it's not just Germany...
For example, during the war in Libya, despite
being a relatively small conflict, just 3
weeks after the attacks began the European
air forces began to run out of precision weapons.
In other words, governments spend money on
large weapons programs – and have many hired
soldiers…
But all that doesn’t matter much on a day-to-day
basis.
That’s how we end up with news like this:
(“The Legion declares an all-out war on
obesity.
The elite unit of the Spanish infantry launches
a forced plan to combat obesity among its
members.”
ElPaís)
But, honestly, wait a moment... because that
isn’t the worst of it.
Perhaps what annoys the US officers the most
are the rules with which some of the European
armies have entered combat under NATO, for
example in Afghanistan.
See, many European governments don’t want
to assume any kind of risk, so they order
their military commanders to maintain their
soldiers away from the front.
In the case of the Afghan campaign, for example,
US soldiers sharing testimonies in which they
were denied medical evacuation by Europeans
because they were in a combat zone weren’t
strange.
Listen up.
(“Afghanistan year 2008.
We were returning from a mission when a rocket
hit the vehicle that was in front of mine.
Our Humvee was suddenly being attacked by
machine gun fire.
Of the 11 vehicles that entered the ambush
area, four were left inoperative and a fifth
one was destroyed.
One of our boys had died and a dozen were
wounded
We were six hours away by car from our base,
it was getting dark and the Taliban were still
attacking us.
When we called to ask for a medical evacuation,
they asked us if the landing area was still
hot.
We said yes, we were being attacked.
At that moment a voice with a foreign accent
told me that their rules prevented them from
providing us assistance.
He asked me if we could secure the landing
area or if we could move.
Minutes turned into hours and the Taliban
continued attacking us.
Then, out of nowhere, a voice came up on the
radio, it was American.
A couple of Blackhawk helicopters, from a
totally different mission, had heard our help
call.
The pilots deviated immediately.
Within 15 minutes they landed and our wounded
were evacuated.
Our superiors told us that the NATO country
who was responsible for medical evacuations
had a rule that prevented them from intervening
in still hot areas.
We were furious”.
Just a second, this is very important.
In Afghanistan alone, nearly 900 European
soldiers have lost their lives.
We’re talking about political orders that
don’t happen in all cases, but which are
very common.
And, no, it's not a matter of money... but
of commitment.
Every year, the European NATO countries spend
almost 300 billion dollars, that is, together
they have the second largest military budget
after the United States.
In spite of this, in Washington they want
European NATO countries to substantially increase
their military spending... and that’s where
the magical 2% of the GDP figure appears.
(THE 2% MYTH)
As he made very clear at the last NATO summit,
Donald Trump is furious.
According to the vast majority of the countries
of the Atlantic Alliance, they’re late in
their quota payments.
Check this out.
(Many countries in NATO, which we are expected
to defend, are not only short of their current
commitment of 2% (which is low), but are also
delinquent for many years in payments that
have not been made.
Will they reimburse the U.S.?. Donald Trump)
Well... one of two is true: either he’s
saying this because he has no idea or he’s
saying it because he wants some electoral
points… by, of course, fooling his voters.
Because, let's be clear, this entire late
payments thing has no point of reference.
See, 2% is a military spending objective,
from each country for its own army.
It has nothing to do with NATO payments or
anything like that.
That is, if a country spends less, it doesn’t
owe anything to NATO, the United States or
anyone else.
But... the fact is that in 2014, after a lot
of pressure, Barack Obama managed to get the
European NATO countries to commit to substantially
increasing their military budget to reach
2% of their GDP by 2024.
And precisely due to that commitment, Europe
is the region of the world where military
spending is increasing the most.
Check it out.
Yes, you know that later Trump and especially
his supporters will say that this was all
thanks to him, to his “magnificent” negotiating
skills.
However, even if military spending increases...
it probably won’t change anything.
First, this 2% figure is a random number,
which could be reached simply by raising military
salaries… or cheating in all kinds of ways.
Greece, for example, is one of the few countries
that complies with this and spends 2.36% of
its GDP... but a large part of that budget
is used to pay for military pensions.
And even most of their investment in military
equipment is geared towards defense against
Turkey... another NATO member country.
The result?
Even though the expenditure rule is apparently
being followed… the Greek army brings little
or nothing to the organization's capabilities.
But even though all of this money could be
used to really improve the armies – and
of course without political commitment it
will never happen – not much will be achieved
anyway.
European countries will continue to depend
on the United States for force deployment…
because each country by its own wouldn’t
be able to afford to maintain that kind of
global deployment, intelligence and supply
capabilities.
And, of course, given that in Europe military
operations aren’t popular, neither the political
commitment nor the rules for entering into
combat will change.
That is, we would have larger armies but at
the moment of truth, very similar deficiencies.
But also, let’s see.
The armed forces can perform four essential
functions:
Deterrence;
Intervention and deployment;
occupation
and 4) cybersecurity
For none of these tasks is the current European
countries budget a hindrance.
To fight terrorism or quickly deploy somewhere
in the world and face a special situation,
you don’t really need multiple aircraft
carriers, that is, redundant forces.
It’s much more important to be able to deploy
quickly and manage a conflict.
For example, there’s the latest United States
and NATO wars: Afghanistan, Iraq and Libya.
In all of them, their military victory was
simple... but the postwar period... was an
absolute disaster.
Preparing forces to manage local conflicts,
and using the different countries’ institutions
to train the national forces--not only the
military, but also police forces and trial
courts, prisons and power plants, etc. would
probably have been a lot more useful.
At the end of the day, dear viewers, facing
a conflict requires a lot of things... and
not always the same ones.
The threats we face today don’t require
aircraft carriers or fighter-bombers, but
agility.
Europe doesn’t need to spend more, it spends
a lot, it needs to spend better.
And that's where the idea of the European
army emerged.
(PESCO, A EUROPEAN ARMY?)
In December 2017, the European Union launched
the PESCO program, the Permanent Structured
Cooperation.
Its objective?
Coordinating the countries that participate
in the program in terms of security, acquisition
of war materials and joint defense and peace
operations.
In other words, to begin integrating the various
armed forces.
The program is still in a very incipient phase
and isn’t considered the equivalent of a
European army.
However... this could be the best solution
to all their problems.
The 25 countries that make up the PESCO program,
by integrating their armies, their weapons
purchases, their training and even by sharing
resources could mean that Europe, even while
spending less, would have a modern, well-equipped
army with great deployment capabilities.
After all, if a country like Spain spends
a fortune buying Leopard 2 tanks, which has
happened, and in practice – due to a lack
of means to deploy them – only uses them
to defend against Portugal, they’ve made
a totally unnecessary expense, don’t you
think?
Folks, today the risks and challenges are
global, so I sincerely believe that Europe
needs more integration, to do things better
and seek to complete the US’s military contributions
within the NATO framework… but not by spending
more.
Almost 300 billion dollars a year should be
more than enough.
But now it's your turn, do you think Europe
should develop its own army?
Leave your answer in the comments as well
as in the survey.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.